padres have been putting together some
runs early in games winning the first
two games of the series tony gonzalez
long major league start this season july
31st gave up just
one hit over four shutout innings and
then went back to the alternate site
when clayton kershaw was activated
but back up tonight for his second start
one down here in the first hand he
brings up trent grisham
this one is in the year to right field
mookie bets on the runs not going to get
there drops in for a hit
as trent grisham has got a base hit one
out one on and brings up manny machado
and this one is to left center field in
for a base hit
over is peterson stopping at second base
is grisham in fact he's got a dive back
manu now has a five-game hitting streak
the 3-2
he did do exactly that split her a
little bit lower to get a swing and a
miss two gone
and now jake cronin worth coming up
lifted to right
routine for mookie belts and godzilla
finds
zach davies on the mound tonight for san
diego his fourth start
two and one record nice era at 2.87 and
loves pitching at dodger stadium 2-0
with a .86 era
so that's aboard with one up andrei's
going into a shift
this is on the ground and it's gonna be
machado to second for one on to first
that is two
double play tony goes to work against
will myers
on a one-two pitch he chases a splitter
three in a row to get myers for the
first down to the second one away for
greg garcia
he gets a swing and a miss on a
four-seam
now here's a 3-2
[Music]
one home run eight runs batted in on the
move
and a terrific pitch man oh man it's
just unhittable right now and that is
strike three call for chris david
another payoff pitch so far sends one to
left jack peterson playing shallowly
makes the catch
on this 2-2 he pulls one sharply to
third for turner
throws him out two away
[Music]
there comes a little spinner in front of
the plate for will smith to complete a
one two three third
with tony gonzalen who's retired eighth
straight
lead runner on for la for the first time
in this one will smith
catch number nine man this is hit on the
ground to third machado to second for
one
onto first for two double play second
double play in three innings turned by
the padres
no score to the fourth with the sun
setting in los angeles and tony gonzalez
on the mound now seven innings in the
majors this season
heath of the lineup here machado fam and
cronenworth
uh he actually got a breaking ball and
swung and missed strike three
but it's owen two now to tommy pham
counseling gets him swinging carving
them up or
he's making me smile because i'm sitting
here thinking this guy can't
pitch in the dodger rotation he's
getting his second spot start
two up two down and a couple k's and
here's jake cronin
and missed strike three so for the
second time
tonight gonslin strikes out the side he
has fans
seven through four that's got a board on
an error in his first halfback
swing and a miss and zach davies picks
up his third k
gets mookie betts to chase two down
turner
first and max muncie coming up the one
and two swing and a miss got him with a
change up but a nice job by zach davies
collecting his second k
of the inning and his fourth of the
night two on with two down here in the
fifth inning so to be up to trynan to
try and keep it scoreless
tati's coming up in a nothing nothing
game in the fit there they go here it
comes he strikes him
out with a tailing fastball to finish
off the fifth
tryna comes in and strikes down tate
here's taylor he's got pollock at first
who runs taylor lays one down this would
be a tough play for machado
he doesn't even attempt to throw a bunch
single for chris taylor
so first and second nobody out here's
rios
hits it sharply deflects off davey's
into right
pawlik headed home and the dodgers take
a one-nothing lead
on an rbi single from edwin rios
as austin barnes comes up barnes shows
bun
lays one down right side throw to second
is light comes off of the bag though and
is out but it's two nothing as taylor
scores on the bunt from barnes the young
bruce stark grader all on to a very
important spot here with a tying run
coming to the plate in the form of
tati's junior dave roberts trusting him
in a big situation here
high leverage inning with a small lead
bounce back to gradual he goes to second
one they
double him up
well from one tenth spot with tatis
representing the tying run to another
machado representing the tying run
the o2 slider to get him swinging
take a bow two nothing lead and a chance
here for bellinger to add on
and what is only the third at-bat for
the dodgers tonight with runners in
scoring position
first one from stamen slices it down the
left field line
a fair ball and it pops into the seats
that's a double for bellinger and they
lead it
three nothing as barnes is in to score
so a three nothing lead and they're at
second and third for turner
turner lifts it in the air to deep
center field grisham on the move he's at
the wall
it's gone turner goes the other way with
a three-run home run to crack it open
and we're thinking right here is this
off the wall or over the wall
justin gets good backspin and carry on
this ball
and it is enough a six-run lead but the
base is loaded and nobody out
definitely the biggest situation
kenley's come in this year
did he go he did one gone first a b
tonight for hedges
sticks with the hard stuff and strikes
him out 94 for out number two
profar trying to keep things alive
ground ball right
side hernandez has it and the dodgers
shut the padres out
six nothing